kehar est seigneur tu aimerais
mauviettes
que ça va et qu'est ce que ça va
des marines ont versé leur sang pour le
corps des marines
et vous croyez que vous méritez de
mourir avec autant de l'air
alors tu vas faire semblant que c'est
une journée comme ils sont tout va bien
aller
d'ici quelques jours vous aurez l'art ou
le devoir vous appelle je t'aime
tellement
tous les canadiens
j'aimerais discuter de l'incident
vous avez traversé une série
d'événements traumatiques
ça suffit excusez moi monsieur je peux
plus continuer aucun danger
j'ai envie que les han été sécurisés
au top
voulez vous enlever la vie gabriel
qu'est ce qui vous en empêche je
comprends la culpabilité
les regrets ce sont tous des sentiments
rendre à l'humain
intéresse
et
[Musique]